e aí ganha pois ela já foi no dentista
como vocês podem perceber na verdade
está acontecendo na sede com esquisito
comigo eu tô com o filho da equipa poder
votar o aparelho porque ficar gato eu
toda uma coceira nesse eu ea equipe está
começando a lacrimejar toda vez que tem
dois perto de mim eu tô com dor no
joelho todo o gado todo lugar esses dias
eu vi que eu quero colocar aparelho na
boca focar brad pitt brad pitt
muitos aqui tem algumas coisas que eu
acho interessante e curioso de ti ti
pois é eu cheguei lá no dentista
acho engraçado que quando a gente chega
no dentista e sempre com aquela cara de
alma vai do senado
só vou arrancar um pedaço de você sem
que você perceba o que é verdade a gente
não percebe a gente vê o dentista
colocar na estadia na nasce liga eu
quero ficar pensando meu deus tomara que
não dou
tomara que não do meu deus vou pedir
poder que estão a colocar devagar para
não doer você vai falar com letícia o
seu dentista coloca na estréia devagar
por mudando no boca já cover se nem viu
o moto saudade de vocês mota depois de
aquela maquininha do barulho irritante
está ligado aquela maquininha que eu
apelidei carinhosamente de satanás nunca
vi um trintão pequeno dá tanto meio acho
que se colocasse um gêiser uma porta e
um dentista pela máquina e outra sem não
é senão eu pude regional hora porque na
real seguinte a máquina faz
você já fica mas por dentro você tá
[Música]
e essa parte que eu acho mais
interessante a máquina vai se
aproximando você vai ficando tenso você
fechou com força aquele que vai dormir e
não está sentindo nada e você não sente
nada e furacão vai pra campo para tirar
a bateria que dengue e nem você não
sente nada meu velho opa matéria que 10
jan lusa o antigo que você bem tranquilo
senti nada na tv é coisa de deus aleluia
meu deus do céu o glória está passando -
teve na etapa nacional não já passa o
efeito da anestesia da minha parte mais
engraçada para que você vai pagar porque
você vai pra casa com um pouco de efeito
da anestesia tipo lutávamos - atrai a
pessoa chega pra te falar aí como é que
foi no dentista responde ótimo oita
alguma coisa de errado e você nem
percebe isso que eu acho graça tudo isso
torna a minha ida ao dentista coisa mais
legal até então o vídeo e se você
assistir no facebook clique em curtir e
compartilhar você compartilha minha
ajuda muito aqui no youtube você tem que
gostei comenta aqui embaixo que você
mais odeia o que você mais gosta quando
vai ao dentista você ainda não está
inscrito neste canal só clicar em
inscrever-se e na estréia passou segue
no twitter segue estagnada assina no
facebook e é isso aí galera nem assistir
o canal